Bonjour tout le monde et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo.
Aujourd'hui, on se retrouve quasiment dans le même cadre,
juste avec l'affiche du film Ghibli, Kiki et la petite sorcière,
parce qu'aujourd'hui, on va parler de films.
J'avais envie d'aborder ce thème qui est de savoir
comment apprendre une langue en regardant des films.
Quand j'ai commencé à apprendre le japonais
et que j'ai commencé à regarder sur YouTube
des méthodologies pour apprendre le japonais,
très rapidement, il y a eu cette idée qui est beaucoup apparue,
qui est d'apprendre le japonais en regardant des mangas,
en regardant des animés.
En général, les personnes qui aiment la culture japonaise
ont connu, ont commencé à s'intéresser à la culture japonaise
par les mangas et les animés.
Et du coup, souvent, quand on regarde sur YouTube
comment apprendre le japonais,
on a souvent cette méthodologie qui dit
regardez plein d'animés,
vous allez apprendre le japonais
très efficacement, très rapidement,
vraiment foncez, regardez le plus possible d'animés.
Et du coup, quand on voit ça,
quand on veut apprendre le japonais
et qu'on voit quelqu'un qui nous dit
regardez des animés,
vous allez apprendre le japonais,
on se dit c'est magique,
c'est sûrement la méthode idéale,
je vais foncer tête baissée,
je vais commencer sans réfléchir
et je vais devenir bilingue japonais.
Spoiler alert,
ça ne marche pas.
Enfin,
on ne devient pas facilement bilingue en japonais.
Et c'était un peu le but de cette vidéo,
c'était d'expliquer,
de donner un peu mes conseils
sur cet apprentissage
par l'immersion,
en regardant des films.
parce que c'est une bonne idée
mais il faut faire attention
à ne pas faire n'importe quoi
parce que ça peut générer
de la frustration.
Quand je voyais tout le monde
qui me disait
tu vas regarder des animés,
tu vas apprendre le japonais,
j'ai essayé,
je n'ai pas réussi
et j'ai fini frustré.
Donc l'idée de cette vidéo,
c'est de vous donner mes conseils
pour faire en sorte
que ce soit une bonne expérience
entre guillemets.
C'est d'ailleurs pour moi
l'occasion de vous présenter
le tout premier sponsor
de cette chaîne,
FluentU.
FluentU est un outil
qui vous permet justement
de regarder du contenu
en pouvant interagir
avec le vocabulaire.
Quand on regarde des films
ou des vidéos comme celle-ci,
on a souvent des sous-titres
à disposition
mais on ne peut pas
interagir avec eux.
FluentU est un outil
qui permet cela.
Si vous ne connaissez pas
un mot de vocabulaire,
vous pouvez cliquer dessus
et accéder à la définition
et à des phrases d'exemple.
Vous pouvez également
sauvegarder le mot,
vous faire une liste de mots
à apprendre
et ensuite utiliser
un système de flashcards,
ce qui est idéal
pour mémoriser
de nouveaux mots de vocabulaire.
Il y a même
une fonction de quiz
qui permet de varier
les révisions.
Quand vous vous inscrivez,
FluentU vous pose
quelques questions
pour créer votre profil
et ensuite vous accéder
à une banque de contenu
adaptée à vos réponses.
Vous pouvez aussi utiliser
FluentU directement
sur Netflix
ou YouTube
grâce à l'extension
Google Chrome.
Une fois que vous avez
regardé des films
ou des vidéos,
vous pouvez revoir
les mots de vocabulaire
sur votre ordinateur
ou même
sur l'application mobile.
Si vous voulez essayer
FluentU,
il y a un essai gratuit
de 14 jours
et vous avez également
un code promo
pour avoir
moins 40%
sur le prix
de l'abonnement annuel.
Donc si vous voulez,
vous pouvez essayer
l'outil
et si ça vous plaît,
vous pouvez bénéficier,
vous pouvez profiter
de la réduction.
Encore merci à FluentU
de m'avoir fait confiance
pour cette vidéo.
Et donc,
on peut reprendre
directement
avec mes conseils
pour un apprentissage
réussi,
une bonne immersion
en regardant
des films.
Mon premier point,
c'est que
si on ne comprend pas,
ce n'est pas amusant.
Alors,
c'est évident,
mais ça implique
plusieurs choses.
C'est évident
que si on ne comprend pas,
on ne va pas
prendre du plaisir
à regarder quelque chose,
mais du coup,
ça pose deux questions.
La première,
c'est qu'il faut
prendre en compte
la difficulté
de la langue.
Plus une langue
est différente
de notre langue maternelle,
plus ça va être difficile
d'accéder
à ce genre de contenu,
de pouvoir commencer
à regarder un contenu
en comprenant.
Si je prends un exemple,
j'ai commencé
à apprendre
le portugais récemment,
eh bien,
très rapidement,
je peux,
j'ai pu
commencer à regarder
des vidéos
et même
des séries
ou des films
en comprenant
un minimum
le portugais,
tout simplement
parce que c'est
une langue
très proche
du français.
A l'inverse,
au début,
quand j'ai commencé
à apprendre
le japonais,
c'est totalement différent,
si je commençais
à regarder
un animé
ou un film,
je ne comprenais
rien.
Et du coup,
ça,
ça implique
une chose,
il faut apprendre
avant de commencer
à regarder
des films.
Ça paraît évident,
mais l'idée,
c'est qu'au début,
quand vous débutez
votre apprentissage,
il faut un minimum
de bases,
il faut apprendre
les bases de la langue
pour pouvoir apprendre
en regardant
un film.
Si vous n'avez pas
ces bases,
ça va être
trop difficile
et vous n'allez
pas perdre
votre temps,
ce n'est pas
une perte de temps,
mais ça va être
tellement difficile
que ça va générer
de la frustration
et vous n'allez pas
réussir à continuer
à regarder des films
dans la langue
que vous apprenez.
Donc,
c'est important
de commencer
à être sûr
qu'on connaît
un minimum
les bases
pour commencer
à regarder
un film.
Et d'ailleurs,
si pendant un film,
vous vous rendez compte
que vous ne comprenez
rien,
commencez point par point
à essayer de voir
ce que vous ne comprenez
pas,
s'il y a des règles
de grammaire,
par exemple,
si c'est la structure
des phrases
ou du vocabulaire.
Je lis mes notes
en même temps.
Mon deuxième conseil,
c'est que c'est bien
de commencer
avec un film
qu'on connaît déjà.
L'avantage
de regarder
un film
qu'on a déjà vu
dans notre propre
langue maternelle,
c'est que
même si on ne comprend
pas certains passages,
on n'est pas perdu.
En ce moment,
en portugais,
je lis
Harry Potter,
je connais bien
et du coup,
même s'il y a
des passages
du livre
que je ne comprends pas,
je sais toujours
à peu près
où je suis
dans l'histoire.
Je connais un peu
les étapes du film
et du coup,
je ne suis jamais
vraiment perdu.
J'ai essayé
de lire
Le Petit Prince
en japonais
et il y a
quelques passages
où j'étais
complètement perdu
et comme je ne connaissais
pas l'histoire
du Petit Prince
en français,
j'étais juste perdu.
A l'inverse,
j'ai regardé
le film
Your Name
en japonais,
je le connais bien
en français
et du coup,
même s'il y a
des passages
difficiles,
je ne suis pas perdu
et je continue
de suivre le film.
Mon troisième point,
c'est
ne soyez pas
trop obsédés
par créer
des flashcards.
Dans une autre vidéo,
j'ai parlé
de l'extensive reading,
extensive immersion
et du coup
de l'extensive
watching
ou listening,
ce que vous voulez.
L'idée,
c'est qu'en fait,
le piège
facile
dans lequel
on peut tomber,
c'est que
quand on commence
à regarder un film,
tout de suite,
il va y avoir
beaucoup de mots
qu'on ne connaît pas.
Le piège,
c'est de vouloir
commencer à créer
des cartes
de mémoire
pour tous les mots
qu'on ne connaît pas.
Et en fait,
si vous faites ça
et que vous ne connaissez
pas suffisamment
le contenu
que vous regardez,
vous allez en fait
mettre pause
à chaque fois.
Toutes les deux secondes,
vous mettez pause
et vous créez
des flashcards.
Et en fait,
là,
ça va un peu
enlever
le goût
de regarder
un film.
Regarder un film,
c'est censé être
amusant,
du bon temps,
sauf que si vous
mettez pause
à chaque fois,
ça va couper
l'histoire
et vous n'aurez
plus aucun plaisir
à regarder
un film.
Donc l'idée,
c'est d'essayer
d'avoir un bon équilibre
entre ce mot
est très important
à connaître.
Je met pause,
je crée une carte
de mémoire
pour ce mot
et juste,
bon,
je ne comprends pas
tel ou tel mot
mais c'est pas grave,
je laisse continuer
parce que
je suis intéressé
par l'histoire
et parce que je pense
que ce n'est pas
très important
pour le moment.
Et ça,
c'est typiquement
une erreur
que j'ai faite
au début
qui est de commencer
à regarder un animé
ou un film
en japonais
et dès qu'il y avait
un mot
que je ne comprenais pas,
je mettais pause,
j'essayais de faire
des cartes,
etc.
Ça,
ça va vous enlever
le goût
de regarder un film,
ça va vous enlever
le plaisir
de regarder un film,
une série
ou une vidéo.
Donc,
essayez toujours
d'avoir un peu
de ne pas mettre
trop pause,
de ne pas trop
arrêter
votre film.
Et l'exemple
que j'ai là-dessus,
c'est que
par exemple,
pour le japonais,
j'ai commencé
à essayer
de regarder
l'animé
Fieren.
Je ne connaissais
pas l'histoire
en français,
donc si je ne
comprenais pas
l'animé,
j'étais complètement
perdu.
Du coup,
à chaque fois
qu'il y avait
un mot
que je ne comprenais
pas,
je mettais pause,
je créais
une flashcard
et du coup,
ma façon
de regarder
l'animé
était très
saccadée,
coupée
et je ne
prenais plus
vraiment plaisir
à le regarder.
Alors que
dans un autre sens,
en ce moment,
comme je le disais,
je lis
Harry Potter
en portugais,
comme je lis
dans mon lit
avec ma liseuse,
je peux seulement
regarder la définition
de certains mots
grâce à la liseuse
mais je ne peux
pas créer de carte
et du coup,
en fait,
je lis
avec fluidité,
je ne m'arrête
pas souvent
sur des mots précis
et du coup,
le portugais
est assez proche
du français
donc je ne suis
pas trop perdu.
Je connais
l'histoire
en français
donc même
s'il y a une page
où je ne comprends rien,
la page d'après,
en général,
j'arrive à me rappeler,
à me souvenir
de la scène
ou du passage
du film
et du coup,
ça me permet
de ne pas être
trop perdu
et de continuer
à lire
sans mettre pause,
sans essayer
de tout comprendre,
sans créer
des flashcards
pour chaque mot
que je ne connais pas.
Donc ça,
c'est vraiment
l'exemple
de ces conseils.
Et enfin,
mon dernier point,
c'est de ne pas
trop vous mettre
la pression.
Je pense que
l'objectif,
le point positif
de cette méthode
de l'immersion
et de regarder
un film,
c'est de prendre
du plaisir.
En fait,
la clé,
c'est vraiment
de réussir
à trouver
un moyen
de prendre
du plaisir
en écoutant,
en regardant
une langue
que l'on ne comprend pas.
Et ça,
ça implique
de ne pas se mettre
trop la pression.
il y a un youtubeur
très connu,
Steve Kaufman,
qui disait
qu'il faut accepter
l'imperfection.
Il faut accepter
que notre compréhension
ne soit pas parfaite
et que parfois,
c'est un peu flou.
C'est un peu...
On ne sait pas vraiment
si on a bien compris.
Si on arrive
à accepter
cette imperfection,
on va être capable
de continuer
de regarder
du contenu,
de prendre du plaisir.
Et ça,
ça veut dire
qu'on va regarder
de plus en plus
de contenu,
ce qui est la clé
pour tout apprentissage
d'une langue étrangère.
Plus vous augmentez
le temps
que vous passez
à regarder du contenu
dans l'immersion,
à regarder des films,
plus ça va être bénéfique
pour votre apprentissage.
Il y aura plus
d'effets positifs
pour votre apprentissage.
Et du coup,
ça,
mon conseil,
c'est vraiment
ne vous mettez pas
trop de pression.
essayez de laisser
aller un peu
le film,
la vidéo
et essayez
d'apprécier
même si vous
ne comprenez
pas tout.
Quand vous voyez
des mots importants,
faites des flashcards.
Si vous ne comprenez
vraiment rien
à ce que vous regardez,
mettez pause
et changez de contenu,
changez de film
ou de vidéo
et au fur et à mesure,
vous allez pouvoir
commencer à progresser
et à accéder
à des contenus
de plus en plus
difficiles.
Voilà,
c'est à peu près tout
pour cette vidéo.
J'espère que ça
vous aura plu.
Si vous avez des questions
sur comment
regarder un film,
si vous avez
d'autres questions
ou d'autres conseils
peut-être à partager,
n'hésitez pas
à utiliser
l'espace
commentaire
qui est là pour ça.
Et moi,
je vous dis
à la prochaine.